reefers pennsylvania and how long have
you been down here Skid Row
now five years five years
and where do you stay previously on
Krakow okay I normally have a tent with
my husband however right now I don't
he's in jail
possession much time to use your
possession normally you don't get that
much time however I think that there may
be trying to go hard on him because he's
had a couple cases before so normally if
you can get out like the same day or a
couple days later but there to holding
him for till November with what drug
abusing heroin
oh we mix it together you mix it
together you smell good sure sure
what is it you started using drugs I
didn't actually well growing up
let's see around age 13 I smoked some
weed from like 13 till like 20 something
and then I quit using drugs altogether
and then I got real heavy into cocaine
for a while sniffing it quit no problem
then I got into crack and I did that for
a good like
Wow and then I stopped doing the crack
and got into heroin how much do you
spend up but it was was your addiction
cost I'd say probably at least the seeds
at least a hundred and something dollars
day so you go 150 27 or 167 well I get a
VA pension and also my husband gets
Social Security so however I quit
drinking yeah I just chose hard drugs
instead yay yeah these are from I'm not
sure what they're from they said that
they were from shooting heroin in my
arms got infected they're doing a lot
better but I don't think that's the case
I don't I don't know what the deal is
they're like really big holes yeah yeah
it'd go pretty deep whoa we've been
together since - well we're not
technically married legally
however we I mean come along
in deliver on the street they take it
guys for them
no I don't do that what do children have
children
Rubick they're in Pennsylvania their dad
I heard the I heard that my one son got
into a car crash
my oldest son and in ended up passing
away I don't know if that's true or not
because I haven't talked to them in
years
- afraid Pocoyo called me weird
they would be c20 like 22 and like 19
two boys tell me buddy shopping my
childhood was great I'm no me child I
don't have any brothers and sisters mom
dad grandma and uncle my childhood was
absolutely wonderful I didn't have to I
didn't go without I mean I didn't get
beat I didn't I know I didn't I I pretty
much was raised by my grandma my mom
worked all the time
my child was wonderful well my mom and
my dad were alcoholics
however they they still maintained a job
we still had everything we needed got up
and went to work every day I mean yeah
they drinking and got messed up or
whatever we get you know but I mean I
mom will wake up in the morning and
crack a beer as soon as she woke up mmm
but I'll tell you what she would drink
all day and night the house would be
clean we would have breakfast lunch
dinner
you couldn't even really tell if you ask
me
I mean given to drinking until I was in
high school I started drinking and and
that got kind of I got carried away with
that and I and I and I drank a whole lot
too much transition to yeah I quit for a
while and I didn't do anything I didn't
do drugs or drink I was completely sober
I went on that Whitney go antabuse I was
on an abuse for like three years and so
for three years I didn't get high I
didn't drink nothing
I didn't like it
but I did it Oh what well and then I
just decided to start doing it again
because I was just everything was just a
doll and it really it was I mean I I
needed something to just change the pace
or do something different and I was
bored and I needed a new feeling I'd
wake up with the same it the same
feeling every day same stuff every day
and it just I forget I'm still drinking
again so I did then when I came to
California when I yeah when I went to
California or wherever I went to go to
school to be a dog trainer certified dog
trainer mm-hmm I did that I didn't
really go too far with that I haven't I
haven't done it yet actually I didn't
finish the school cause in my back I
mean that's how I met my husband and my
husband had invited me over to have a
cup a few beers and I never left we've
been together
did you talk to your family I don't have
any family they're all dead
yeah my mom my dad my gram
my aunt's my uncles
I think one of them want to write one of
my children are diseased
I think I'm not sure I'm I'm kind of
frightened to do so because I mean I
first of all I held him call would that
be my firstborn child passed away I knew
nothing of it I was out doing drugs
drinking partying I'm not I never even
knew anything about it yeah I'm not
really the end of that ya know so I
haven't called to find out I apologize I
mean I know that's an awful thing to say
that I I'm not ready to uh well like
there's nothing I could say that's it's
so I can't I can't
I mean I could but I have it and I don't
know if I will
the next five years were thought to be
give it back I don't know
I don't know
and then my other son I'm like even if I
did reach out to him I'm gonna say hey
how you doing I [ __ ] up I'm still
[ __ ] up on the streets you know I
can't I can't do that but I don't think
that's not this isn't where I want them
to see me oh the last time you saw me
you know I went into the military you
know I was strong I know look I can't
you